اوكرانيا للشرق الاوسط وافريقيا اهلا بك
سيد مكسيم نبدا بهذا المؤتمر التي تشارك
فيه اوكرانيا اليوم في الدوحه مؤتمر الامم
المعني بالدول الاقل نموا ما هو السياق
الذي تشارك فيه اوكرانيا في هذا المؤتمر
ما هو الهدف من هذه المشاركه وما هو
المؤمل تحقيقه منها شكرا بدايه اود القول
بان الوفد الاوكراني يشارك هنا بناء على
تعليمات من الرئيس زينينسكي الذي تلقى
دعوه خاصه رسميه من كل من الامين العام
لونه المتحده السيد بوتيريش وكذلك امير
دوله قطر
وبالتالي اوكرانيا ورغم الحرب التي شنتها
ضدها روسيا والتي لا تزال تخوضها اوكرانيا
اوكرانيا عازمه على تاكيد دورها الفعال
كلاعب اساسي وضامن للامن الغذائي العالمي
لان ملايين الناس وعشرات الدول في افريقيا
وشرق الاوسط واسيا تعتمد اعتمادا كبيرا
على صادرات القمح الاوكراني فكان لابد
لاوكرانيا وفيها ان يكون ممثل في هذا في
هذه الفعاليه وهذه التظاهره الاجتماعيه
والانسانيه الهامه والكبيره
ونهنئ دوله قطر على احتضانها لهذه القمه
الخامسه وبالتالي اوكرانيا منذ ان اطلقت
مبادرتها المعروفه بالحبوب من اوكرانيا او
جرين فروميوكرين التي اعلن عنها الرئيس
زيلينسكي في نوفمبر من العام الماضي تعتزم
اوكرانيا ارسال ما لا يقل عن 60 سفينه
محمله بالحبوب باتجاه القاره الافريقيه
وبعض الدول الاسيويه والعربيه ايضا وفي
هذا الاطار استطاعت اوكرانيا ان تجمع
تبرعات حجمها 200 مليون دولار تقريبا التي
ستخصص من اجل ارسال القمح الاوكراني
باتجاه الدول الاكثر حاجه اليه وقد قلت
بان اوكرانيا عا على يعني المزيد من
القيام بدورها كضامن
للضمان الامن الغذائي العالمي كما تقول
كانت هناك مساعي حاليا لتمديد هذه
المبادره كيف تقيمون اولا تطبيق هذه
المبادره وما الذي يمكن ان يعيق تمديدها
مجددا نحن طبعا كنا متفائلين جدا عندما
تمديد العمل باتفاقيه القمح والحبوب التي
سمحت لاوكرانيا بنقل الحبوب باتجاه الدول
الافريقيه والاسيويه عبر مضيق بوسفور وذلك
بوساطه تركيا وبساطه امميه طبعا التي
اقنعت الجانب الروسي بضروره فتح الممرات
البحريه لامام السفن الاوكرانيه لكن للاسف
الشديد نرى بان روسيا تهدد بين الحين
والاخر تهدد بنواياها بغلق هذا الممر
بتعطيله وافشانه هذا هذه مساله خطيره جدا
لا يمكن السماح لها بان تحصل لان ملايين
الناس يعتمدون على القمح الاوكراني والقمح
من البحر الاسود بصفه عامه
ونحن ايضا يعني نتساءل لماذا على السفن
الاوكرانيه ان تخضع للتفتيش بينما السفن
الروسيه لا تخضع لاي تفتيش وهي الحقول دون
ان يتم تكرار ذلك مجددا في الحقيقه نحن
نطالب روسيا برفع الحصار عن كافه الموانئ
الاوكرانيه الواقعه في البحر الاسود وكذلك
في نفس الوقت نعرف بان هذه المساله مساله
صعبه جدا وروسيا لن توافق عليها بسهوله
لكن مع ذلك نحن نحاول ان نقنع الجميع
بضروره زياده
موانئ جديده على هذه الاتفاقيه كي تشمل
اتفاقيه اكثر من ثلاثه موانئ لانها بالفعل
كلما زاد عدد الموانئ الاوكرانيه كلما
ازداد حجم الصادرات من الحبوب والتي هي
ستوفر الامن الغذائي للعالم ككل والتي
ستمنع ستمنع ارتفاع الجنون حقيقه الذي حصل
والذي شهدته الاسواق العالميه في الاونه
الاخيره فيما يتعلق بماده الحبوب
المج الدولي فيما يتعلق بهذه المبادره
وتنفيذها على الارض نحن نرى ان هناك دعما
قويا لنا من قبل المجتمع الدولي بصفه عامه
وايضا من كان من المهم جدا لنا او دعم
قضيتنا عندما اكد المجتمع الدولي بان
العقوبات التي فرضت على روسيا لم تشمل وهي
لا تشمل حتى الان المواد الغذائيه او
الحبوب او الاسمده فكل الروايات المضلله
التي ينشرها تنشرها روسيا بان العقوبات
الدوليه هي سبب في نقص ماده الحبوب او
الاسمده في الاسواق العالميه هي عاريه عن
الصحه ولذلك لابد لروسي ان تتعاون مع
اوكرانيا مع المجتمع الدولي في هذا المجال
وان تضمن سلامه وسلاسل حركه ثلاثه حركه
السفن الاوكرانيه عبر البحر الاسود
تحدث عن الحرب بشكل اعم الان سيد صبح كيف
اعادت هذه الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
صياغه الاولويات الاوكرانيه خاصه ما يتعلق
منها
بالبنيه الاساسيه في التنميه والاوضاع
الانسانيه كذلك طبعا العدوان الروسي على
اوكرانيا تسبب في خسائر فادحه في الاقتصاد
الاوكراني وفي البنيه التحتيه تعرفون بان
روسيا قد دمرت ما يزيد عن 50% من منشات
الطاقه في اوكرانيا ففي هذا السياق طبعا
اوكرانيا اولا تتلقى الكثير من الدعم
الخارجي وليس فقط العسكري وانما ايضا
المدني والانساني
والكثير من المساعدات الانسانيه تاتينا من
كل حدب وصوب ومن كل دوله والكثير من الدول
ومن بينها بلدان عربيه يعني مشهود لها
بتبرعاتها السخيه لصالح الشعب الاوكراني
فطبعا لابد هنا ان ننظر الى ضروره اعاده
اوكرانيا ما بعد الحرب ولكن حتى هناك
مشاريع بنيويه كبيره تنفذ حاليا على الارض
بتمويل خارجي وهناك فرصه لكل الدول المحبه
للسلام بان تشاركنا في اعاده اعمار
اوكرانيا وهذه فرصه سانحه لكي تكون او
تصبح اوكرانيا اوكرانيا جديده يعمها الخير
والسلام وذلك بايادي ودوليه عالميه ومساعي
حميده من قبل المجتمع الدولي نستطلع معك
الان اخر التطورات المتعلقه السياسيه
المتعلقه
بالوضع الاوكراني
وتحديدا المساعي الدوليه التي تتحدث عنها
في عقد
مؤتمر دولي
للتسويه
وفق الرؤيه الاوكرانيه هنا هل التمسك بهذه
الصيغه الاوكرانيه يمكن ان يعزز فعلا فرص
التوصل الى هذه التسويه في الحقيقه
المبادره التي اطلقها الرئيس زيلينسكي
والتي تسمى بصيغه السلام هي تعود
القمه الاخيره التي انعقدت في بالي على
مستوى مجموعه دول العشرين الكبرى ووقتها
اعلن الرئيس زيلينسكي عن هذه المبادره
التي تشتمل على عشره محاور اساسيه فهذه
المحاور الاساسيه العشره التي ذكرها
الرئيس زيلينسكي هي اساس هي وضعت او
استخدمت كاساس وارضيه
للقرار الاممي الذي صيغه في الامم المتحده
والذي صوتت عليه اكثر من 141 دوله لصالح
هذا القرار فهذا يعني ان القرار انه خطه
السلام الاوكرانيه اعتمدت اعتمدت رسميا
على مستوى
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده ونحن نرى
بان هذا المسار هو بالفعل سيحقق السلام
وندعو جميع الدول النظر في هذه في خطه
السلام او صيغه السلام التي اقترحها
ونؤمن بان تنفيذ ما ورد فيها من بنود
سيضمن ليس فقط هدنه كما كما قد يشاء البعض
ولكن سيضمن سلاما دائما وشاملا وعادلا
للجميع لكن الى اي مدى هناك مساحه
للمراوحه من قبل كيا فيما يتعلق بهذه
الرؤيه او هذه الصيغه للسلام بما يتماشى
مع مبادرات او رؤى اخرى لوقف الحرب وتحقيق
السلام في اوكرانيا والله في الحقيقه نحن
يعني نقدر كل المبادرات التي تصلنا وكل
يعني
البرامج والخطط التي تسعى من خلالها تلك
الدول او الاخرى لاحلال السلام في
اوكرانيا
ونحن مستعدون للجمع بين تلك
المقترحات والمقترحات التي تقدمنا منها
بها لكن المهم ان تلبي وان تنفذ روسيا
ايضا هذه المقترحات وهذه المبادرات واول
دوله وجهها وجهها كلمته ودعوته ونداءه لها
كانت روسيا والرئيس قال بان هذا الخطه اول
دوله يجب ان تلتزم بها هي روسيا وان
التزمت بها فسيحل السلام في اوكرانيا وفي
روسيا وفي المنطقه ككل شكرا لك مكسيم
الصبح مبخوت اوكرانيا الخاص للشرق الاوسط
هو افريقيا شكرا